the left-hander making his first start
since the all-star break comes out to me
to lead it off
popped him up
zabala looking for
[Applause]
it he kept his mask in the other hand
this time sebby had this one all the way
here's uh jordan alvarez oh for his last
18
2-2 homie struck him out that was on the
outer portion well-placed fastball
carlos's fastball is one of the most
difficult to hit in baseball oh yeah
here's the one-two
swinging miss
down goes guriel on 99 at the top of the
strike zone bottom half of the first
inning from valdez working on six days
of rest goes to the mound today so an
alrighty lineup for frober valdez and he
gets the first pitch bounced towards
jose altuve he'll have to hurry and does
to get tim anderson who grounds out on
the first pitch of the afternoon that he
sees two out and abreu at first base
andrew vaughn looking for his first in
in the series
little tapper that martin maldonado will
bare hand and make a strong throw to get
andrew vaughn and the inning good inning
for proper valdez carlos correa over his
last 20.
makes quick work of correa
five batters faced he's got three
strikeouts
when correa saw the ball it was
literally in the middle of the plate
when he swung it almost was against his
right knee so
it would be billy hamilton
jake leaning back toward first the pitch
is a ground ball to second base altuve
will tag berger on his way and throw it
away from first base hamilton is safe
well jake berger
did something well there which was
slowed down
by the time he did run into the tag
number one he forced caltubay to come
get him and number two there was no
chance first and second now with two
away and a chance for danny mendick
hamilton will score
danny mendick
from the nine spot gives the white sox
the lead this time he drills it right by
correa into left field
now with a one-nothing lead will face
the bottom three there's a 2-2
swing and a miss
high fastball gets miles straw strikeout
number four for carlos rodon there's
that high fastball with the late life
and the location
not a whole lot of guys can get on top
and hit that here's the nine hitter
martine maldonado
he strikes out two gone that's just high
he throws it right by him and knowing
that he's probably going to be a bit
tardy on that high fastball carlos hits
the spot perfectly with two out now and
jose altuve stepping in for the second
time 2-2 pitch
cut out and missed another slider from
carlos it's strikeout number six nothing
socks lead to engel abreu and vaughan
against kromber valdez
curveball lined towards short on one hop
what a pick by carlos correa and another
kick on the other side by eule
guerrielle
correa and guriel combining for a fine
play to get the speedy angle great play
all around right there put on stake to a
one-nothing lead here in the top of the
fourth here's the 2-2
check swing did he go yes he did
strikeout number seven for carlos second
time he's gotten jordan alvarez real the
right-hander
strikes out again
phil wrote down now 10 consecutive
starts of at least eight strikeouts
but we're only in the fourth inning and
he's got eight of them already
the dh today
driven deep
a laser sixth home run of the year 41st
driven in
and this is what the sox really need is
you want monkata to get back to being
juwan monkatta
and that means power from both sides of
the plate that was a line drive rocker
one out here's tim
[Applause]
but he will hit out in the right
and it's gone
he's got a 15-game hitting streak it's
three nothing there's your multiple home
runs and tim for the second time in as
many days
takes it out to right field 75 pitches
for carlos looking to cruise through the
six full count here's the pitch
called strike three
that's number ten ouch carlos rodon is
in all kinds of control right now
against the houston astros carlos rodon
is back out for more here in the top of
the seven one two to curiel swung on
popped up a brayer will take a couple of
steps behind first in fair territory
makes the catch and there's two out in
the top of the seventh two down michael
brantley the batter
burger chasing after it and he'll get it
in foul territory
seventh inning stretch time still three
nothing socks mendic at second with one
out engel the man in charge of taking
advantage of that miss play by toro
and it is four nothing
you ask for an extra run
and adam engel
provides it
against andrew vaughn already four
nothing
on the ground infield in altuve comes
home and they have the runner caught up
nowhere for him to go with the runner
already at the bag maldonado is going to
tag both just in case but to bring you
on the bag
that's going to be a
double play that's a great play by
maldonado because
engel overran the bag when it was his
bag
that's exactly right so he overran the
bag instead of staying on the bag
in which there would have only been one
runner out which would have been a
brilliant trail runner for the ball game
it is michael kopeck on to the 19th time
he's been in the right place a lot he's
three and o's correa is all for his last
22
a little flare
and hamilton's got it
a little indecision
but he recovered in time
well billy hamilton has make up speed
and if he can get close he's going to
take that dive and make the play mendic
gives way he can't get it billy comes on
and makes the catch
liam hendricks coming out for the 41st
time non-safe situation he's just trying
to get an inning of work before
hopefully maybe a couple of saves
tomorrow jason castro on to hit from
martina maldonado
that's going to be out number two
picked by abreu on the low throw two
down jose altuve with two out and nobody
on
it
and the white sox
pull off a combined one hit shutout